die korona epidemie ist in europa
angekommen in italien auch unser
gesundheitsminister jens spahn spricht
von einer geänderten lage in europa
lange war es ja so dass es vor allem
viele infektionen in china gab in europa
eben nur vereinzelte fälle aber das hat
sich geändert mittlerweile gibt es in
italien mehr als 320 corona infektionen
und mindestens zehn todesfälle und auch
in österreich der schweiz und spanien
gibt es seit heute neue infizierte die
nähe das ist das was verunsichert auch
wenn viele experten sagen kein grund zur
panik und deshalb heute darüber sprechen
was bedeutet das alles jetzt eigentlich
für uns hier in deutschland und zwar
besprechen wir dass mit professor
susanne herold von der uni gießen und
dort expert sind für
infektionskrankheiten guten abend herr
herold frau hier rollt müssen wir damit
rechnen dass sich das corona virus jetzt
auch in deutschland ausbreiten wird
ja es ist im moment so dass das virus
europa erreicht hat und das ist wirklich
nicht unwahrscheinlich dass wir auch in
deutschland zunächst vielleicht einzelne
infektionen haben werden es werden dann
sicher maßnahmen ergriffen um
infektionsketten auch zu unterbrechen
aber ja damit ist zu rechnen zum
aktuellen zeitpunkt glauben sie denn es
könnte sogar schon jetzt fälle hier
geben die einfach noch nicht entdeckt
worden sind
die schwierigkeit bei der korona
virusinfektion ist in der tat dass
infektionen auch sehr symptom arm
verlaufen können möglicherweise sogar
fast symptomfrei
insofern war das auch ein problem
natürlich in china weil man da nicht gut
detektieren konnte welche patienten
überhaupt infiziert waren und das ist
immer für eine eingrenzung schwierig in
deutschland aber ist zum aktuellen
zeitpunkt stand heute die lage oder die
gefahrenlage als gering einzuschätzen
und ist es nicht im moment davon
auszugehen dass leute aktuell
symptomfrei hier sind aber ansteckung
oder ansteckungen verursachen können
dennoch muss man natürlich jetzt sehr
genau gucken und die behörden tun dass
wo patienten herkommen ob sie kontakt
hatten zum patienten oder zu menschen
die infiziert waren und zb in regionen
waren die italien wo das video ist jetzt
im moment auch ausgebrochen ist
das wollen wir gleich noch vertiefen und
dann auch mit euren fragen die es schon
einiges bei uns eingelaufen
ihr könnt natürlich wie immer einfach
hier unten in die kommentarspalte eure
kommentare und fragen posten da gehen
wir dann gleich darauf ein jetzt wollen
wir aber erstmal auf die aktuelle
situation in italien schauen dort haben
sich heute mehrere
eu-gesundheitsminister getroffen auch
jens spahn und andreas postel berichtet
am bahnhof der norditalienischen
metropole mailand sind die
atemschutzmasken ausverkauft es ist
etwas weniger betrieb als sonst am
bahnsteig die passanten haben gemischte
gefühle im gepäck
es geht ein bisschen die angst um wir
sind aus rom jetzt hier ferien zu machen
verunsichert uns die rote zone die
abgesperrten ortschaften in der
lombardei sind nur 60 kilometer entfernt
hier im krankenhaus in córdoba nahm die
verbreitung ihren lauf zu spät war bei
einem 38-jährigen die infektion
diagnostiziert worden
die beiden hotspots in der lombardei und
venetien bleiben bis auf weiteres
abgeriegelt die italienische regierung
zeigt stärke um nicht schwach zu wirken
aus südtirol der emiglia romana und auf
sizilien wurden vereinzelt neue
infizierte gemeldet
die auswirkungen auf wirtschaft und
tourismus sind in italien schon jetzt
spürbar premierminister konnte versucht
zu beruhigen
italien ist ein sicheres land ein land
in das man reisen kann auch als tourist
es gibt einige wenige zonen unseres
staatsgebietes die begrenzt zugänglich
sind aber im rest des gesamten landes
kann man beruhigt reisen
am abend treffen der gesundheitsminister
in rom
es gibt lob für die massnahmen italiens
und gemeinsame verabredungen für das
weitere vorgehen
wir sind gemeinsam der meinung dass zu
diesem zeitpunkt jetzt
reisebeschränkungen oder gar das
schließen von grenzen keine angemessene
verhältnismäßige maßnahme wäre dass es
angemessen ist im einzelfall zu
entscheiden ob auch größere
veranstaltungen stattfinden so hat
italien entschieden fußballspiele in der
serie a im betroffenen norden ohne fans
als geister spiele stattfinden zu lassen
also ich fast noch mal zusammen die
städte bleiben erst mal dort abgeriegelt
über großveranstaltungen soll im
einzelfall entschieden werden und die
grenzen
die bleiben erst mal offen und dazu
kommt eine passende frage hier bei
youtube von melanie und die schreibt der
virus wird als äußerst aggressiv
dargestellt geben diese maßnahmen
wirklich sicherheit vor einer ansteckung
das würde ich gerne an sie weitergeben
professor hier wollt
diese maßnahmen sind sehr zielführend
denn es geht jetzt in solchen regionen
wo es ausbruchsgeschehen gibt
massenansammlungen von menschen zu
verhindern denn gerade dort können
natürlich oder kann das video ist er
sehr leicht weitergegeben werden vom
einen zum anderen und das kann ein
mensch sehr sehr viele andere menschen
gleichzeitig infizieren
insofern sind diese maßnahmen ganz
korrekt und auch sinnvoll auch das virus
wirklich so aggressiv ist wie sie es
jetzt beschreiben kann man so im moment
nicht stehen lassen das virus hat im
moment eine mortalität von ungefähr zwei
prozent
das kann gut sein dass wir aber im
verlauf das noch herunter korrigieren
werden denn es gibt möglicherweise viele
unentdeckte infektionen und es ist
wahrscheinlich nicht viel aggressiver
als die virusgrippe dass wir gleich noch
drauf eigentlich wird gerne gerade noch
bei den massnahmen bleiben
da kommen nämlich auch noch einige
fragen und zwar vor allem auf den fall
berichtet dass wir auch hier in
deutschland bald mehr fälle haben
da fragt zum beispiel lilly wie sieht
denn dann der plan aus und gianluca hat
angst dass dann die kapazität der freien
betten nicht reicht sind wir da gut
darauf vorbereitet
ja das ist natürlich eine wichtige frage
wir bereiten uns aktuell 3 vor
wir werden von den behörden im moment
auch darauf angesprochen und es wird
gemeinsam abgesprochen wie wir im
zweifelsfall wenn wirklich viele
patienten auftauchen diese patienten
unterbringen können
da gibt es pläne die liegen in der
schublade da gibt es ganz klare
verfahrensanweisungen zu aber man muss
auch sagen wir kennen eigentlich so ein
szenario das trifft uns ja jeden winter
mit der influenza welle mit der
grippewelle manchmal mehr manchmal
weniger stark aber wir nennen ja immer
die grippewelle von vor zwei jahren 2017
und 18 wo es ja 25.000 todesfälle in
deutschland gab unglaublich viele
infizierte und auch damit kommen wir ja
mit unserem gesundheitssystem im moment
klar und auch das können wir handeln
insofern sind wir gut vorbereitet wir
haben ein sehr sehr gutes
gesundheitssystem in deutschland und die
behörden machen das gemeinsam mit uns in
den kliniken und ja wir sind
zuversichtlich dass auch bei größeren
ausbruchsgeschehen das gut ablaufen wird
die ami hat schon mehrmals im vergleich
zur grippe unsere grippewelle gezogen
warum gibt es denn jetzt gerade beim
corona virus wenn das doch so ähnlich
sein soll so eine weltweite aufregung
wären es ja bei der grippewelle von
vielen einfach ignoriert wird
das ist eine wichtige frage zumal die
krippe ja auch eine erkrankung ist die
man durch eine impfung verhindern kann
oder zumindest ihren verlauf sehr stark
abmildern
es ist natürlich so das virus ist ein
neues virus und man kennt es noch nicht
so gut wie man die krippe kennt wobei
man aber auch sagen muss corona viren
infizieren menschen schon sehr lange es
gibt vier verschiedene bewohner wären
die auch saisonal also jährlich und bei
uns erkältungskrankheiten machen
insofern sind jetzt ist das neue virus
kein ganz unbekannter und das ist ja
auch ähnlich dem sars virus was auch
ganz gut charakterisiert wurde
mittlerweile dennoch ist es natürlich so
ein bisschen die angst vor dem neuen und
man weiß nicht so genau welche bereiche
im atemtrakt des virus jetzt genau
infiziert wie die molekularen
mechanismen sind der infektion der
vermehrung den menschen und der
weitergabe
insofern ist natürlich auch etwas
vorsicht jetzt an den tag zu legen
aber sie sagen das ganz richtig wenn man
das mit der grippe vergleicht sollte man
eigentlich sehen das wie gesagt wir
darauf vorbereitet sind und wir solche
arten von erkrankungen durch viren eben
auch eigentlich kennen sie sagen schon
vorsicht an den tag legen und die kommt
tatsächlich einige kontakt kommentare
von euch die hier gerade auflaufen und
fragen unter anderem zur sterberate auf
was junge menschen betrifft
mortalitätsrate können die sich erhöhen
und eine frage die fast das vielleicht
ganz gut zusammen von ani wer ist
gefährdet wahrscheinlich ernsthaft zu
erkranken
ja das sind wichtige fragen natürlich
auch für entsprechende maßnahmen wenn
man jeden treffen müsste es ist schon so
dass die meisten patienten die an der
infektion versterben ältere patienten
sind und patienten die vorerkrankungen
haben das können zum beispiel chronische
lungenerkrankungen sein dass nun aber
auch herzerkrankungen sein oder diabetes
und diese patienten sind eben oder diese
menschen sind besonders gefährdet
schwerer zu erkranken
es ist durchaus aber auch so dass hier
und da in selteneren fällen mal junge
patienten auch schwerer erkranken können
das ist aber nichts spezifisches für des
krone virus und das kennen wir auch von
der influenza das passiert von zeit zu
zeit aber wie gesagt die gruppe die
risikogruppe sind jetzt wirklich die
älteren patienten und die frau erkrankte
patient so wie verhalte ich mich richtig
dass es auf jeden fall eine frage die
hier an vielen stellen auf kommt auch
die frage was ist denn jetzt eigentlich
mit künftigen urlaubsreisen und darauf
hat nina niebergall ein paar antworten
wo sollte ich nicht hinreisen
das auswärtige amt rät generell von
reisen nach china ab für die provinz
hubei gibt es sogar eine ausdrückliche
reisewarnung viele airlines fliegen
gerade auch gar nicht nach china
lufthansa zum beispiel hat alle flüge
bis ende märz ausgesetzt
für andere länder gibt es noch keine
reisewarnung wo sich das virus aber
rasant ausbreitet in südkorea etwa oder
im iran fahren züge womöglich nicht mehr
werden flüge abgesagt und auch in
italiens abgeriegelte städte kommt im
moment kein tourist
was aber tun wenn der urlaub in
gesperrte orte führt da kann man
kostenfrei vom reisevertrag zurücktreten
wenn man gar nicht hinkommen kann dann
ist das ein fall von unvermeidbaren
außergewöhnlichen umständen dass es kein
problem das gilt auch für den
individualtouristen der zum beispiel nur
ein hotel gebucht hat wenn ich gar nicht
anreisen kann in die region dann kann
ich kostenfrei hier zurücktreten das
gilt auch wenn das auswärtige amt vor
reisen warnt zumindest für
pauschaltouristen oder wenn es bei der
hotelbuchung im vertrag steht
kann ich eine reise aus reiner vorsicht
kostenlos stornieren nein das geht nicht
in solchen fällen liegt kein fall der
außergewöhnlichen und unvermeidbaren
umstände vor
denn es besteht keine objektive
gefahrenlage oder es ist auch nicht mit
erheblichen beeinträchtigungen zu
rechnen
manchmal sind reiseveranstalter aber
kulant und auch airlines bieten an flüge
umzubuchen für alle die im moment lieber
nicht nach norditalien wollen
das war jetzt vor allem die rechtliche
seite professor herold ich würde sie
gerne nach der medizinischen sicht
fragen soll ich jetzt also auf meine
reise nach italien zum beispiel
verzichten
es gibt im moment keine reisewarnung für
italien es ist aber doch so dass man
jetzt nicht in die ganz betroffenen
gegenden reisen sollte also es gibt
einige zone neben in der lombardei die
man jetzt aktuell vielleicht nicht
bereisen sollte das kann man auf der
webseite des robert-koch-institutes auch
nachlesen wo das genau ist wenn ich
jetzt aus dem venedig urlaub zum
beispiel gerade zurückgekommen bin und
habe jetzt plötzlich erkältungssymptomen
es kratzt im hals
was mache ich dann also wenn sie kontakt
zu jemandem hatten der eben nachweislich
erkrankt ist ist das ganz klar wenn sie
jetzt aber wirklich aus einer region
kommen die im moment als risikogebiet
definiert ist und da muss ich auch
nochmal auf die webseite des
robert-koch-instituts verweisen da wird
immer tagesaktuell werden risikogebiete
aufgelistet wenn sie daherkommen und
tatsächlich jetzt erkältungskrankheiten
haben dann sollten sie am besten
ihr lokales gesundheitsamt
benachrichtigen und fragen wie sie
weiter vorgehen sollten dann wird
wahrscheinlich ein abstrich gemacht oder
eine probe genommen werden und es wird
geschaut ob sie das mit dem kuchen virus
infiziert sind
sie sollten nicht einfach so eine
notaufnahme oder eine arztpraxis
aufsuchen ohne vorher bescheid zu geben
denn falls sie wirklich infiziert sind
ist die gefahr dass sie andere menschen
dabei anstecken sehr groß sondern sie
sollten zum telefon greifen und sich
informieren bei den entsprechenden
stellen die eben genannt wie sie am
besten jetzt weiter vorgehen und da
bekommen sie auch eine eingehende
beratung ist ein großes thema hier im
netz ist auf jeden fall wie schütze ich
mich persönlich und eine sache die hier
gefragt wird da geht es ums händewaschen
michael fragt dort bei facebook bleiben
durch händewaschen noch viren auf der
haut so dass das benetzen der hand mit
desinfektionsmittel besser wäre ja es
ist so dass man natürlich jetzt nicht
bereit überall in der bevölkerung
desinfektionsmittel benutzen kann es
gibt solche mittel die man in der
drogerie kaufen kann aber wir empfehlen
im moment einfach häufiges händewaschen
mit seife also auch länger nicht so ganz
kurz sondern länger des intensives
händewaschen mit seife ist reduziert die
anzahl der viren auf der hautoberfläche
relativ gut vielleicht nicht so perfekt
wie ein entsprechendes
desinfektionsmittel aber man kann damit
die videos belastung deutlich reduzieren
und das ist was was wirklich jeder
machen kann und auch tatsächlich in der
erkältungssaison immer geraten wird
nicht nur im moment mit der momentanen
situation mit dem corona
dann können sie es tatsächlich mal
genauer erklären weil reicht es einfach
kaltes wasser zehn sekunden darunter mit
ein bisschen seife oder muss ich das
jetzt mal intensiver machen wie muss ich
genau das händewaschen anstellen ja also
wir sagen und dabei intensiv die hände
mit seife reiben und dann abspülen
dann kommen hier noch fragen zum thema
mundschutz was ja durchaus umstritten
ist soll man dem benutzten solche frage
die man bei facebook
ob es nicht alleine schon deswegen
sinnvoll ist wenn man sich selbst mit
der hand an die nase an den mund fast
was man ja aus versehen zwischendurch
vielleicht mal tut dass das dann ein
selbst schützen könnte ja es gibt keine
guten daten dass der mundschutz vor
einer infektion schützt im moment es
wird auch nicht geraten dass jetzt jeder
man sich mit mundschutz bewaffnet
sondern wir wissen dass ein mundschutz
dann insbesondere gut schutz der mann
selber erkannt ist also im sinne des
schutzes der anderen menschen aber es
wird im moment tatsächlich nicht
empfohlen
mundschutz einfach so zu tragen bis zum
aktuellen zeitpunkt hier und jetzt in
deutschland für alle die sich vielleicht
gerade ein bisschen über den ton wundern
die klimaanlage bei ihnen professor
hierold ist glaube ich an gegangen also
das erklärt das rauschen was sie gerade
hören
also was haben wir hier noch so viele
fragen hier kommt noch einiges zu
behandlungsmöglichkeiten wird es bald
einen impfstoff geben dass es auf jeden
fall eine frage die hier auf eigentlich
allen plattformen gestellt wird
forscher arbeiten intensiv an neuen
impfstoffen zum beispiel hier im
deutschen zentrum für
infektionsforschung aber auch an anderer
stelle auch weltweit
es wird aber sicherlich nicht so sein
dass ein impfstoff zur verfügung steht
jetzt während des aktuellen ausbruchs
das dauert mindestens im jahr
das muss durch klinische prüfungen gehen
das muss natürlich auch sicher sein der
impfstoff insofern ist nicht damit zu
rechnen dass akut jetzt um dieses
ausbruchsgeschehen zu mindern war
abzuschwächen
ein impfstoff zur verfügung stehen wird
und wurde übrigens gerade bestätigt dass
es tatsächlich einen elf toten
in italien gab die meldung kommt hier
gerade ansonsten gibt es hier einige
fragen bei youtube die wir am besten
noch mal besprechen weil sie vielleicht
auch zeigen was so im netz alles im
umlauf ist
was vielleicht auch durchaus gar nicht
stimmt und zwar fragt hier an
bei youtube in china ist das virus im
grundwasser nachgewiesen worden
was bedeutet das für das trinkwasser in
deutschland und ich will jetzt einfach
mal die frage stellen kann drohen virus
überhaupt durch trinkwasser übertragen
werden klären sie uns mal auf
nein das virus ist nicht über das
grundwasser übertragbar
das ewz hält sich auch gar nicht lange
im wasser zum beispiel das virus braucht
immer um sich zu vermehren
einen menschlichen wirkt also eine zelle
in dieses eindringen kann
weil es den apparat das wird es und der
zelle benutzen muss um überhaupt sich
vermehren zu können also im wasser ist
das virus sicherlich nicht infektiös und
das hat für uns auch hier in deutschland
überhaupt keine bedeutung
eine ähnliche muss mit übertragen durch
tröpfcheninfektion durch durchsprechen
und daneben auch wenn man sich ins
gesicht fasst wenn man ihn kurz vorher
ein patient zum beispiel an einen
türgriff gehustet hat oder mit ihm die
hand gepostet hat an einen türgriff
gefasst hat und ich fasse dann direkt
dran und fassen wir ins gesicht also
über so eine art direkte
schmierinfektion kann das auch
übertragen werden primär eben durch
niesen husten und sprechen aber nicht
durch das grundwasser ok eine ähnliche
frage kommt hier von alex bei youtube
der fragt kann das virus durch mücken
übertragen werden
ein klares nein das funktioniert mich
dafür ist das virus nicht gemacht andere
erreger werden durch mücken oder solche
vektoren wie wir sie nennen übertragen
aber nicht dass wir runden okay da
klären wir jetzt hier schon ein bisschen
auf und hier ist eine frage die zeigt
auch so ein bisschen finde ich das schon
so eine leichte angst einfach um
verunsicherungen besteht
andrew fragt bei youtube soll man sich
einen notvorrat an lebensmitteln und
wasser anlegen wenn ja für wie lange ist
es klug
nein da gibt es im moment überhaupt
keine keine keinen grund für das zu tun
es ist im moment ja wie gesagt in
deutschland die gefahrenlage als niedrig
eingestuft wir haben bisher keine
infektionen in deutschland und wir haben
auch schon garnicht unkontrollierte
infektionsketten insofern ist es im
moment nicht zielführend und auch nicht
angeraten
also ich fasse zusammen professor
susanne herold sagt noch ist die
gefahrenlage hier in deutschland niedrig
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen
dass sie sich heute die zeit für uns
genommen haben und für die vielen fragen
der zuschauer und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch bei euch sind wirklich
eine menge fragen auf gelaufen ich hoffe
wir konnten viele davon beantworten
die nächsten live stream gibt es hier
nächste woche dann mit daniel und ich
sag jetzt tschüss
[Musik]